ya quelques semaines du la chance d'être
invité par razvan marculescu chercheur
au cnrs et co organisateur du concours
al kindi notamment pour rencontrer les
lauréats du concours qui a vu le nombre
de filles tia et après ça on dit encore
que les maths et informatique s'est
réservé aux mecs j'ai passé un moment
super sympa entre passionnés
razvan et moi en avons profité pour
parler de turing la seconde guerre
mondiale et de l'importance de la
cryptographie dans les sociétés modernes
d'ailleurs la vidéo de notre
présentation est disponible sur scène ce
forum et surtout j'ai eu l'occasion de
découvrir l' approche innovante est
incroyablement efficace
le race ban et de ses collègues pour
faire découvrir à des jeunes de manière
excitante ces domaines obscur que sont
les mathématiques et l'informatique
mais ça je vais laisser la semaine vous
le dire al kindi c'est un concours
policier s'est ouvert aux classes de 4e
as quant à la seconde
le prof de la classe et vous amène dans
la salle informatique
là vous passez sur internet pendant 45
minutes des questions de cryptographie
ni comme si ça peut faire peur ni je
vous invite à aller faire un tour sur
les archives du site casser les codes
c'est avant tout un jeu passionnant qui
ressemble beaucoup plus à un kent dick
roche qu'au cours de n'être classique à
l'école
les gens prennent beaucoup de plaisir à
faire ça ensuite la première moitié sont
qualifiés pour le tour d'après où ils
ont à moi en groupes de quatre
pour essayer de casser des codes lasser
les gens prennent beaucoup de plaisir à
découvrir il arrive à trouver un petit
bout un jour après ils reviennent
quelques jours plus tard par certaines
équipes m'ont raconté qu'il prônait le
petit déjeuner sur internet en train de
communiquer et pendant ce temps là il se
pensait pas c est ce que on va faire
comme ça et qu'on va faire comme si ils
avançaient sur le concours et casser les
codes comme ça et ça c'est super league
est trop cool
oui parce que mes critiques récurrentes
du système solaire vinci qui est super
scolaire et du coup il pousse les élèves
à d'un shooter apprendre beaucoup trop
mécaniquement et avoir peur de l'échec
or pour devenir fort en mathématiques en
informatique le plus important je pense
c'est de trouver ça fun en fait il faut
trouver ça tellement
qu'on est prêt à faire des mathématiques
à des moments inopportuns par exemple au
petit-déjeuner et le fait qu al kindi et
réussi à faire faire des maths et des
collégiens et des lycéens au petit
déjeuner c'est complètement fou le
concours fini avec une phase finale qui
ce qui se passe à paris au mois de mai
et qui regroupe les meilleurs candidats
de chaque académie
donc on a des candidats de toute la
france par exemple cette année on avait
des candidats de la guyane ensuite on a
aussi des candidats qui viennent des
lycées de l'étranger donc j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer les lauréats et
lauréates de ce concours est vraiment
impressionnée vous savez souvent en
concurrence le confiance et va poser des
questions rhétoriques et n'attends pas
de réponse est personne va vraiment
réfléchir et s'est trouvé une réponse à
ces questions là moi aussi j'ai posé des
questions autorités pendant la
présentation du genre ce code là d'après
vous c'est quoi
tant que je tourne la tête il était déjà
en train de chercher la solution dans
leurs caisses
ça c'est vraiment trop trop cru mais bon
là je parle des lauréats devront
cheminer le rien ils sont votre traffort
mais le truc que j'ai trouvé vraiment
fou avec al kindi c'est que ça a l'air
d'avoir intéresser beaucoup beaucoup
d'élèves y compris ceux dont on pourrait
penser qu'ils ne sont pas forcément les
bons élèves de la glace le nombre de
participants total et plus de 47000 à la
deuxième édition
il a triplé par rapport à la première
édition
on s'attend que ça augmente encore et
que c'est c'est tant mieux ça n'est pas
restreint en petits groupes
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas un groupe
fermé qui fait un concours de
mathématiques et qui prend plaisir c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui a vocation à
être partagé en particulier un truc trop
cool avec andy c'est que vous n'avez
rien besoin de savoir
en fait il ya vraiment pas de
de handicap pour les élèves de 4e il n'y
a pas de de mathématiques du programme
de la seconde qu'il faut utiliser
il faut vraiment avoir il faut que
savoir casser les codes de ça va casser
de code trouver des idées comment faire
d'être créatif donc petit à petit c'est
vrai que en général les élèves de
seconde arrive bien mais il n'y a pas un
élément concret qui les avantagent n'y a
pas de prérequis de cryptographie non
plus donc c'est pas parce que vous allez
lire des livres sur la cryptographie que
vous allez forcément être beaucoup
meilleur que les autres
les codes ce ne sont pas des codes
secrets
ce ne sont pas des codes classiques
qu'on lit dans les livres en fait pour
être sûr que les codes sont le concours
est vrai on invente des codes secrets
pour l'occasion où parfois on cherche
des codes qui ont été historiquement
mais ils sont réellement obscur qu'on
pourra pas tester tous les coups ne va
pas commencer à tester les codes des
allemands avec eux des japonais et tout
pour trouver dans pour se préparer pour
le concours à qui de toute façon ça sera
un concours vrai semprun le qu'il faut
tout simplement venir et il faut pas
avoir peur ni des pré requis ni du
niveau en mathématiques
normalement c'est sensé à faire plaisir
à tout le monde d'ailleurs chaque
exercice à trois niveaux de difficulté
facile intermédiaire est très difficile
le concours est organisé par deux
associations qui font plein d'activités
pour les lycéens de mathématiques animat
et de informatique france et ensuite on
est soutenus de la force par le
ministère de l'éducation et le ministère
de la défense et on a des sponsors
parfois les
les instituts de recherche et l'année
dernière on a fait un sponsor
industriels c'est le leader mondial de
cartes gemalto
bref si vous êtes élève au collège ou au
lycée ou si vous êtes parents d'élèves
au collège ou au lycée ou si vous êtes
professeur de collège ou de lycée ont
saisi demandé à avoir votre classe
inscrits au concours al-kindi et
parlez-en autour de vous histoire de
diffuser la passion est l'intérêt pour
les mathématiques et informatique ou
tout simplement pour stimuler des
collégiens ou des lycéens avec des
problèmes très intrigant alors pour
l'instant il semble que ça n'existe
essentiellement en france mais quelque
chose me dit que ça va pas en rester là